[Música]
el obispo católico nicaragüense Rolando
Álvarez habría sido devuelto a prisión
luego de que fracasaran la negociaciones
entre el gobierno y los representantes
de la iglesia sobre los términos de su
posible Liberación según medios locales
el sacerdote se habría negado a
abandonar el país
el ministro del interior de Colombia
señala a la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional por el secuestro de
una Sargento y sus dos hijos de seis y
ocho años esto vísperas de un cese de
operaciones ofensivas de las partes
previsto para comenzar este jueves 6 de
Julio previo a La tregua bilateral
pactada con el gobierno colombiano
miércoles de paro rotativo en el metro
de Buenos Aires los trabajadores piden
reducciones de la jornada laboral para
estar menos expuestos a las besto que
habría provocado la muerte de tres
trabajadores se trata de un material
cancerígeno para quienes exponen a él de
manera prolongada
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de France 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias del continente
americano soy Santiago aristie
comenzamos en Nicaragua donde hay
versiones encontradas sobre si el obispo
católico Rolando Álvarez Fue excarcelado
o no la Fuente es oficiales dicen que
por unas horas salió de la prisión la
modelo en medio de las negociaciones del
gobierno con la conferencia episcopal y
el Vaticano pero lo habrían devuelto
luego de que él se negara a salir del
país mientras que religiosos dicen que
todo es especulación nuestro
corresponsal para Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo nos amplía la
información cabe decir que el hermetismo
atraviesa la información que proviene
desde Nicaragua lo que hemos podido
recabar en las últimas horas justamente
con medios locales agencias
internacionales que citan a Fuentes
diplomáticas Y eclesias
eclesiales es que sí hubo una
excarcelación de monseñor Rolando
Álvarez pero que las negociaciones para
sacarlo del país entre conferencia
episcopal de Nicaragua los enviados del
Vaticano y el régimen de Ortega
fracasaron de manera que habría sido
devuelto a la cárcel la modelo Donde ha
estado retenido durante varios meses
Pero mientras se conocía esta
información el cardenal Leopoldo brenes
que es el arzobispo de Managua refutó
desmintió lo dicho por estas Fuentes
aludiendo a que en ningún momento el
obispo Rolando Álvarez ha salido de la
cárcel calificó de especulaciones esta
noticia estas noticias de la
excarcelación Aunque cabe decir que ni
brenes ni Álvarez si han visto la cara
en todos estos meses pero las fuentes
eclesiaste
eclesiales y diplomáticas insisten en
que durante las pocas horas de la
excarcelación pues Rolando Álvarez
habría estado resguardado en la
conferencia
episcopal solo solo que él no quiso irse
Porque la única manera de él salga de
Nicaragua es que o se lo ordene el papa
o se lo pida el propio Papa Francisco
hacemos con más noticias en France 24 el
expresidente de El Salvador Mauricio
Funes fue condenado a seis años de
prisión por evasión fiscal el tribunal
de San Salvador lo culpa por no haber
declarado una renta de más de 270 mil
dólares durante 2014 en el último año de
su mandato presidencial sobre Funes
recordemos pesas una pena de cárcel de
14 años por haber negociado una tregua
con las pandillas sin embargo hay un
obstáculo para que ingrese a prisión Y
es que el ex mandatario vive ahora en
Nicaragua y es ciudadano de ese país que
no permite que estos sean extraditados
y el secretario de estado estadounidense
Anthony blinken prometió apoyo adicional
en seguridad para Haití durante un
encuentro con el Primer Ministro Ariel
reafirmó la ayuda a las fuerzas de
seguridad haitianas y pidió apoyo
internacional para combatir el crimen en
el país los funcionarios se reunieron en
Trinidad y Tobago en el marco de la
Cumbre de la comunidad del Caribe
caricom que celebró El Aniversario
número 50 de su creación
y el ministro del interior de Colombia
Luis Fernando Velasco llamó a la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional el eln a tomar medidas
inmediatas para liberar a una Sargento y
a sus dos hijos de seis y ocho años a
quienes señala de su secuestro esto en
vísperas de un cc de operaciones
ofensivas de las partes previsto para
comenzar este jueves 6 de Julio previo a
La tregua bilateral pactada con el
gobierno colombiano en France 24
dialogamos con Francisco daza
coordinador de la línea paz posconflicto
y Derechos Humanos de la fundación paz y
Reconciliación de Colombia acerca de si
se ve comprometido el cese de las
hostilidades en efecto pues ese tipo de
hechos son no lunares que no favorecen
para nada el inicio y el César fuego
entre el eln y las fuerzas militares
también pues parte de el inicio de este
css pues sería bien acompañado en este
caso la liberación de las y sus dos
hijos y también pues la suspensión de
acciones militares por parte de esta
estructura Armada ilegal contra la
fuerza pública Esperamos que del seis al
tres de agosto haya esta suspensión de
acciones y que también haya alivios
humanitarios para la población civil de
las zonas donde el eln tiene una
injerencia territorial vamos ahora hasta
Washington la capital de Estados Unidos
porque este miércoles el servicio
secreto confirmó que la sustancia
hallada en el ala oeste de la Casa
Blanca el domingo pasado es cocaína la
portavoz presidencia el Karim champier
aseguró que las autoridades están
investigando quién pudo haber dejado la
droga en el lugar los detalles de esta
noticia no los entregó desde Washington
nuestro corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez
el servicio secreto encontró cocaína en
la planta baja de la Casa Blanca el
domingo en la noche el hallazgo se dio
cerca de donde se instruye a Los
visitantes que tomen tours del ala oeste
de la casa blanca y que dejen sus
celulares así lo revelaron en Washington
tres personas familiarizadas con la
investigación en el ala oeste La Casa
Blanca está entre otros el salón oval
que es la oficina del presidente la sala
del gabinete la sala de situación y la
sala roosev entre otros para hacer estos
tours además se requiere aprobación
previa de alguno de los oficiales de la
Casa Blanca los invitados pasan por un
control de seguridad antes de ingresar y
después se les pide que dejen sus
celulares en cajas pequeñas Ahí es donde
se habría encontrado la cocaína según un
funcionario entrevistado por el medio
político va a ser muy difícil encontrar
el responsable incluso con cámaras de
seguridad cabe mencionar que el
presidente va a ir el estado en durante
el fin de semana
y no ingresó a la casa blanca sino el
martes para la celebración del Día de la
independencia al respecto Karen Jean
Pierre jefe de prensa de la Casa Blanca
No aclaró ni el lugar específico ni la
hora ni sí habrá posibles consecuencias
para el responsable se limitó a decir a
pesar de las preguntas que el servicio
secreto está investigando y que se va a
llegar al fondo del asunto miércoles
comparo rotativo en el metro de la
Ciudad de Buenos Aires en Argentina los
trabajadores exigen una reducción de la
jornada laboral para estar menos
expuestos a las de esto que ya causó la
muerte de tres trabajadores este
material posee unas fibras que provocan
cáncer a quienes expongan
prolongadamente a él la asociación
gremial de trabajadores del subte y
premetro denuncia que el gobierno de la
ciudad no tiene la voluntad de dialogar
y reclama un plan de desafitización
hasta ahora en vigilancia médica
solamente hay 2.500 sobre esos 2500
trabajadores que están en vigilancia
médica en tres años es decir no sabemos
lo que pasó antes ni si obviamente mucho
menos lo que va a pasar con esos dos mil
y pico ya tenemos 87 trabajadores con
neumoconiosis y producto del asbesto
tenemos siete trabajadores con cánceres
producto de las vetos y tres
trabajadores fallecidos Ese es el número
con dos mil y pico y en tres años esto
desgraciadamente va a subir porque ya
sabemos es una enfermedad que tiene un
periodo de latencia que van a aparecer
la posibilidad avanzamos con más
noticias la Organización meteorológica
Mundial advirtió de climas extremos en
América Latina en su nuevo informe
regional esta entidad de la Organización
de las Naciones Unidas señaló que en
esta parte del mundo hay un círculo
vicioso que se agrava por los choques
climáticos y su impacto en las
comunidades el organismo también
puntualizó Que las temperaturas en la
región han aumentado un promedio de 0,2
grados Celsius por década en los últimos
30 años hablamos de la mayor tasa de
todo el mundo
ya se encuentra disponible para su
descarga la red social de mensajería con
la que meta pretende competir con
Twitter tuvo su puntapié inicial este
miércoles aunque con problemas de
descarga y finalizó de esta manera la
espera después de que la empresa
tecnológica dirigida por Mark Zuckerberg
adelantará su lanzamiento inicialmente
previsto para el jueves y aunque se
trata de una llegada al mercado con dos
grandes excepciones Y es que no tienen
acceso los países de la Unión Europea ni
tampoco los teléfonos Android
es todo por el momento sigan en France
[Música]